what up guys welcome to the just pearly  things youtube channel today um  this is my advice  for the ladies on the channel okay  this is my advice  do not complain about your ex  don't do it on social media  don't do it to your friends don't do it  especially don't do it to guys that  you're interested in  keep it brief  say just didn't work out we wanted  different things whatever broad  because what happens when you complain  about your ex  you are telling this guy i don't know  how to pick men  i can be easily deceived  okay  or you're saying i'm still emotionally  invested and i'm not over it  trust me  don't talk about your ex  don't do it on social media i've been  there okay  it's not a good look don't do it  subscribe subscribe if you like my  channel